marre d'être enfermé dans un 30 mètres
carrés cerné de béton sans envergure ni
horizons après le confinement certains
ont tout quitté pour le grand air mais
faire table rase du passé n'est pas sans
conséquence plongez dans le quotidien de
trois couples qui ont décidé de changer
de vie
[Musique]
céline et philippe rentrer chez eux
entre midi et deux avant le déjeuner
philippe for men son chien à meursault
faire une balade dans leur propriété
forestière
un luxe que ces parisiens apprécient au
quotidien depuis quelques mois
depuis qu'ils ont fait de leur résidence
secondaire en sologne leur lieu de vie à
plein temps même temps les canards au
milieu des arbres
le chien qui est bien vains voilà c'est
on se ressource complètement entre mu et
ferme
moi j'ai cette chance de me ressourcer
entre midi et deux et je repars détendu
donc c'est non c'est vraiment très très
différente de la vie parisienne
en fait on en rêvait depuis toujours de
pouvoir vivre ici mais on subissait un
rythme classique de salariés et
finalement par l'obligation du
confinement s'est retrouvé ici donc
c'est vrai que ça a été une épreuve
grandeur réelle que cette villa était
possible en terre bien que paris soit
seulement à une heure et demie de train
s'installer ici ne s'est pas fait sans
difficulté là j'ai dû par exemple me
faire suivre par un dermato j'ai eu
en fait c'était impossible de trouver un
dermato près d'ici donc j'ai dû
retourner à paris pour pouvoir avoir un
rendez vous dans un délai convenable
c'était pas figurer que ça pouvait poser
un problème l'autre problème rencontré
c'est la connexion à internet très
mauvaise chez eux dès le déconfinement
ils ont pu louer ses bureaux à la
pépinière d'entreprises de la communauté
de communes de vierzon à 15 km de leur
domicile
moi j'ai besoin de ce calme et ici je
les trouvais c'est très agréable de
travailler avec la lumière avec le calme
avec de l'espace et moi un environnement
de travail qui est agréable et puis le
chemin pour venir jusqu'ici c'est à
travers les forêts dans ses bureaux
céline et philippe sont choyés par
emilie l'assistante de la pépinière
d'entreprises quand ils sont arrivés
mon but a été de les installer de mettre
la connexion internet surtout de faire
connaissance avec eux et puis en
apprenant à les connaître mais je vois
un peu avec quelle autre entreprise tu
peux les mettre aussi en rapport et
enfin on a aussi un peu le bonus est en
fait qu'on imaginait pas parce quand on
a choisi de venir ici c'était surtout
pour l'infrastructure pour l'équipement
on avait besoin d'une connexion
on n'imaginait pas avoir tout ce bon
côté en fait la dimension à la fois
sociales passer un moment agréable avec
avec d'autres personnes et puis là
l'ouverture en fait que ça procure sur
des activités différentes et qui nous
enrichissent en fait une ouverture
professionnelles mais aussi personnelles
et non en fin de journée céline et
philippe retrouve emily chez emi
oenologue et jeunes vigneronne elle
partage son expérience avec philippe qui
possède aussi quelques vignes dans le
sud près de montpellier
content mais c'est un peu en dessous de
ce qu'on imaginait d'accord c'est bien
d'entendre naturellement ses batteries
par céline et philippe ne sont pas les
seuls parisiens à vouloir s'installer au
vert à une ou deux heures de la capitale
d'après le site seloger.com plus de la
moitié des personnes qui recherchent des
biens à vierzon vie en ile de france
il faut dire que c'est la ville la moins
chère de la région
en moyenne le prix au mètre carré
s'élève à 840 euros
juste après vient châteauroux avec le
mètre carré à 1100 euros soit dix fois
moins cher qu'à paris mais l'immobilier
n'est qu'un des paramètres à prendre en
compte quand on change de vie surtout
quand on quitte tout c'est le cas de
stéphane et cécile
mais voilà mon ce potager j'ai pas fait
tout seul évidemment on s'est retrouvés
confiné avec ma femme
confiné dans le sud de l'indre le couple
a soigné ses tomates courgettes et
tournesol sur ce lopin de terre qui
appartient à la famille de stéphane
reconnecter à la nature qu il a fait le
choix d'abandonner définitivement la
région parisienne disons que ça faisait
quand même quelques années que j'avais
j'avais l'intention de venir m'installer
ici
mais le confinement m'a fait faire le
dernier pas ça me semblait évident tout
ça stéphane a certes le logement cette
maison familiale de 160 m² ses amis
musiciens aussi avec qui il forme un
groupe
[Musique]
mais il lui manque un emploi cet ancien
directeur de centre de loisirs
accompagne aujourd'hui des personnes
handicapées un métier où le travail à
distance est impossible c'est un tout
petit peu compliqué parce qu il va ya il
va falloir un temps un peu intermédiaire
je dirais un temps de reconstruction
disons que je crois que je vais trouver
du travail parce que j'ai quand même un
un cv autour du social qui est je peux
avoir plusieurs types de boulot
différents mais effectivement je préfère
avoir pauvres c'est pas le mot mais je
préfère être pauvres ici qu'être pauvre
à paris voilà je trouve que on peut
espérer un peu plus ici ce qu'il espère
c'est une meilleure qualité de vie avec
des produits achetés dans cette ferme
qui lui rappelle son enfance
surtout il attend sa femme reparti en
région parisienne c'est s'il ne pouvait
pas tout lâcher d'un coup ok on avait
l'envié d'aller vivre là bas mais mais
mais on se donnait jusqu'en 2021
et effectivement balade du coup oui moi
je suis un petit peu chamboulé aussi je
gère donc ma fille elle habite encore à
la maison
ll a perdu là son emploi elle travaille
dans un restaurant sa ferme et donc
voilà donc moi je j'ai besoin d'être
sereine savoir qu'elle en sécurité aussi
voilà il ya plein de petites choses à
régler
alors qu'elle prépare une expo sait s'il
doit aussi passer son permis de conduire
et trouver un travail d'animatrice dans
le sud de l'indre ce matin elle a
d'ailleurs un entretien téléphonique
avec châteauroux métropole qui l'aide
dans ses recherches
c'est un petit peu compliqué c'est toute
petite petite ville est en fait je me
rends compte que c'est beaucoup sont
beaucoup d associations qui gèrent le
côté animation au niveau des écoles
c'est pour ça que c'est important vous
rencontriez mon collègue pour qu'ils
vous parlent de tous et tissu associatif
à l'autre bout du fil caroline forestier
avec ses collègues elle aide les
nouveaux arrivants à trouver un travail
mais aussi en logement ou une crèche
donc on disait vous avez été un peu de
difficulté à trouver un médecin si j'ai
la peau un dispositif d'accompagnement
gratuit lancé en 2012
moi j'ai accueilli environ 100 familles
parents et on a commencé au début on
était à 30 familles
on est passé à 40 et là ou alors qui est
le confinement je suis déjà à 66
familles et on n'a pas fini l'année donc
on voit bien qu'il ya une demande
la collectivité organise aussi des
soirées pour faire découvrir à ces
familles des endroits atypiques comme
l'aéroport de châteauroux une visite
organisée avec l' agence d'attractivité
de la rumba qui constate elle aussi un
regain d'intérêt pour le département
depuis le déconfinement
questionner
on a eu un bon baromètre c'est qu'on a
réalisé une campagne dans le métro
parisien en début début d'été qui a
généré 15 contacts actifs
donc ils sont soit des personnes qui
connaissaient déjà département qui se
trouve à venir des personnes aussi qui
me connaissaient pas du tout et qui va
qui se posent la question va que de
changer de cadre de vie
combien sont ils aujourd'hui à quitter
les grandes villes pour venir en région
centre val de loire
difficile à dire certes cécile stéphane
céline et philippe passe sous les radars
des agences des notaires mais d'autres
indicateurs montrent un essor des achats
de maisons et d'appartements dans une
agence bancaire en banlieue orléanaise
le président du comité régional des
banques fait un constat clair le nombre
de prêts immobiliers a explosé depuis
mai par rapport à l'année 2010 9 qui
était une des meilleures années de
crédit habitat débloquer de tous les
temps il y à une augmentation là sur la
région centre de 10% de plus mais on
reste encore loin de la ruée vers la
campagne si des secteurs comme montargis
où le perche ont connu une forte
progression des achats de biens depuis
le confinement les trois lieux qui
attirent le plus ce sont des villes
orléans chartres et tours
c'est d'ailleurs à tour que viennent
d'emménager ben oué naël et leur fils
vigo
[Musique]
les jeunes parents ont acheté cet
appartement au centre-ville de tours
sans 2019 bon il reste encore pas mal de
cartons malgré tout ils n'ont pu y
emménager qu'à la mi-septembre à cause
des travaux de rénovation et surtout de
la crise sanitaire
une crise qui les a poussés à quitter
définitivement paris pour tours houben a
grandi on était dans un processus avant
la qu'ovide et puis juste après ça voilà
quoi la même s'ils ont été faites
22 l'appartement de son appartement à
paris et vit ici complètement ça offre
beaucoup d'avantagés on a une heure de
paris c'est super actif on est tout de
suite en dehors de la ville très
rapidement et nous on va souvent chinon
wind à l ébène envisage d'ailleurs de
quitter tours pour chinon d'ici trois à
quatre ans il se projette à plus long
terme dans cette demeure qu'ils doivent
acquérir très bien ton tout à parti du
tsoup qu'on peut aménager en brûlant
c'est vrai que chine on était aussi une
région privilégiée qui a été moins
touché par par la pandémie dont c'est
vrai que aussi on est un peu rassuré par
sa j'avoue et le fait de pouvoir être de
toute façon quand même à l'extérieur
dans la nature dans son jardin sa la
patrie gwenaëlle et ben ont trouvé leur
future maison grâce à cette agence
immobilière avant le confinement les
biens se vendent est ici en quelques
mois désormais s'ils sont au prix du
marché
ils partent en quelques jours une
activité de plus 30% moins par rapport à
l'année dernière et e
nous sur le chiffre d'affaires de
lagence nous avons récupéré les trois
mois de confinement donc 15 au 15 août
donc c'est vraiment très bien et plutôt
inespéré et on a encore beaucoup de
demandes
voilà il nous manque des biens à la
vente les prix n'ont pas encore grimper
mais avec cette pénurie de biens il
pourrait un peu augmenté dans des villes
comme orléans
les parisiens n'en seront pas forcément
tenus pour responsables ils ne
représentent en moyenne qu'un quart des
acheteurs
loin de l'image du conquérant étrangers
beaucoup sont avant tout des exilés en
quête de leurs racines
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai challenge
mais j'ai l'impression que justement
tous les citadins se remettre un petit
challenge à travers à travers ce qui se
passe
en fait on est en train de redécouvrir
passe nos campagnes construit quelque
chose quelque chose de nouveau
construire une nouvelle vie voilà
peut-être les 20 dernières belles années
qu'on a à vivre et c'est vachement
intéressant de se dire que ça peut se
faire ailleurs
[Musique]
depuis qu'on a cette maison moi je me
dis vraiment c'est l'endroit où je me
sens je me sens le mieux sur terre
c'est vraiment un sentiment d'être au
bon endroit
[Musique]